more now on strikes this winter and
government plans to keep essential
Services moving 1200 members of the
armed forces are being deployed to drive
ambulances and staff border posts to
tackle strikes this winter we'll be join
now by the chancellor of the dusty of
Lancaster Oliver Dalton Mr Dowden thank
you so much for joining us on Sky News
good morning good morning
I want to start with the nurse's strike
it's the first in NHS history it's a
good place to start I suppose is there
any wriggle room when it comes to pay
the NHS is a special case one could put
it to you
um nurses are using food banks are
unable to finish shifts because they
can't hand over to anyone because
there's no one to hand over to do you
not think there should be an adjustment
from the government and there should be
a resolution to their pay
well you're right that the NHS is a
special case that's why for example last
year when public sector pay was frozen
across the board and we had gave a three
percent pay rise for for all those
across the NHS and that's why this year
we gave it to the independent pay review
body and they came up with this number
which for the lowest paid across the NHS
in fact everyone got 1 400 pounds and
for those on low pay clearly that's a
much higher percentage months ago yes
but at the time that that was that
decision was made the independent pay
review body was aware of rising
inflation that's why for example they
had a particular Target on for those on
Lower incomes now of course I would
dearly love to give nurses the 19 pay
rise that they would like as with the
the Prime Minister but the reason why
we're not able to do that is for two
reasons first of all the impact on
public finances if we gave just that
inflation across the board to everyone
that would cost households a thousand
pounds per household over the course of
the next year in addition to that and
those of your viewers with longer
memories will remember what happens if
we allow in payments to to get out of
control we do that does Stoke inflation
now what I want to do is make sure these
this initial economic stability that
we're restoring means we grow the
economy have a stronger economy and we
can afford higher pay Rises the
government is seeking to be reasonable
in its approach and I would urge all
unions to be reasonable and to to engage
rather than to strike those figures are
quite interesting Mr Dowden because it's
28 million households you're saying
it'll cost each household one thousand
pounds
um to meet this pay rise where did you
get those figures from because if we
look forward inflation is set to drop to
5.5 percent in 2023
um 2024. that figure could be from
around 400 to 500 pounds per household
so
are you misleading the public here well
if if the unions are are willing to
accept 5.5 percenters as you suggest
that's a that's a totally different
proposition and for a number of people
in the the public sector that is
essentially what this pay settlement
amounts to their demand is to have
inflation at the current level and for
some it's what's called RPI which
another measure inflation plus five
percent which takes you up to 19 so that
that's a totally different proposition
but the problem that we're seeing here
is that more nurses are leaving the
profession than coming into it and one
of the ways that you could secure a
future for nurses is pay
yes and we have given a a pay review a
pay rise determined by the independent
pay review body but that's not the only
thing we're doing we're recruiting a
large number of additional nurses we've
got a target of 50 000 we're halfway
along the path for that for example last
year the Royal College of Nursing asked
for bursaries of five thousand pounds or
in previous years they've asked for
bursaries of five thousand pounds not
repayable to help people get into the
profession we've given that I think
we've given support with training I
think up to about a thousand pounds so
we're taking a wide range of measures
it's not just in relation to pay
but the root out of this is pay
many nurses are saying we can't continue
in this job we can't heat our homes we
can't pay our bills and yet two years
ago we all clapped for the NHS and for
nurses isn't this the time to resolve it
before Christmas to ensure the safety
of the public
well I desperately want us to have a
resolution I would say to all unions to
call off these strikes and to give
people a break over Christmas give
families a break and give the the
military uh break in respect of of
nurses is precisely because of the value
that we hold them in that we broke the
overall freeze in public sectors
in addition and in uh addition to that
of course it is the case that people
will be able to get all sorts of other
supports for example there's 400 pounds
in relation to uh payments for energy
there's 150 pounds look how sustainable
is this at the moment though because the
chief of Defense staff is saying look
you these contingency plans that you've
brought in place to have 1 200 military
personnel Drive ambulances isn't enough
it doesn't go far enough are you worried
about the Christmas period and and also
if someone calls up uh Emergency
Services they dial 999 they've broken a
leg a pensioner has fallen over what
will happen in that time how long will
an ambulance take to get to them
well you've you've raised a number of
different points and I think it's
important that I try and address each of
those uh for the benefit of your viewers
now in relation to the ambulance strikes
we have expressed significant concern
about the impact that that will have and
we would urge ambulance strike leaders
to call it off even at this late stage
we are taking a range of contingencies
whether that's 600 military personnel
for driving 150 supporting in other
roles whether that's getting additional
clinicians into the 999 call centers to
make sure that people are dealt with on
the calls or whether that's getting
volunteer responders as well we are
working incredibly hard to make sure
particularly in the most
urgent cases people are able to get that
ambulance now the advice Remains the
case that if you have a serious
life-threatening uh incident that you
should still be able to call 999 if you
have uh lesser problems you should use
111 as before and you may seek to to use
a transport to get to a hospital
yourself the only way we can remove all
of this impact the only way is for this
to be called off this is not a situation
that we want to be in
so Mr Dalton how are talks going with
unions in particular the Royal College
of nurses how is it going where are we
at at the moment well remember the Royal
College of nurses doesn't relate to the
ambulance right that relates to the to
the license
and the the health secretary continues
to engage with with all unions relevant
to his sectors on on an ongoing basis
and that we we want to find a resolution
to this but the the house
are you hopeful there will be a
resolution of course I'm hoping that
there will be a resolution and I
desperately want I would love to be able
to sit here now and say to you and say
to all of your views and particularly
say to those nurses we will give you a
19 pay rise
and the reason why the reasons
if you allow me to finish my point
please the reason why that can't be done
is because of the costs the public
finances of an nineteen percent pay rise
if you think about across the private
sector many of the people listing public
and private sector are getting about
four percent that would be increased to
19 that would have a huge impact on
public finances it's not my money it's
not the government's money it's your
viewers money that is being spent we've
gone over here
I don't think it would be a reasonable
and that fig has been disputed of one
thousand pound every household
our viewers don't like to be misled
well I'm not misleading your viewers and
forgive me if you if you would please
not keep interrupting me I might be able
to get some of these points out in
relation to the value in relation we
want to hear from so they want to know
why a pay rise isn't possible and you're
telling our viewers that it would cost
them one thousand pounds and that's
simply been disputed
if you'll allow me to answer the please
go ahead
the the thousand pounds relates to if we
gave across the public sector an
inflation pay rise that would be a
thousand pounds for every household
that's 28 billion pounds in fact the
number would be higher if we matched the
RPI plus five percent that's the 19
which is being demanded in the RCN
dispute now as Government ministers we
have to balance up very difficult
choices we have to make sure the sums
are up for the public finances we have
to balance across what people are
getting in the wider private sector
which is about uh four percent and we
have to balance up the inflationary
impacts of this and the reason why and
the reason why we remit the reason why
we remember the reason why we remit this
to an independent pay-review body is
precisely to take the politics out of
this and it's not just me saying this
this is what for example the shadow
Chancellor for the labor party is also
said we to respect the independent pay
review processes I think that's a
reasonable approach to take the
government is being reasonable in
relation to this I completely understand
the pressures that people are on under
across the public and the private sector
for example with the the war in Ukraine
driving up the the cost of oil and
energy as we recover from the covid
crisis but I would say to union leaders
please give people a break this
Christmas we've got winter biting last
year we had the threat of lockdown
hanging over us things like the the
ambulance strike and the the rail strike
and not what families need this
Christmas Mr Dowden uh I don't think you
answered my question there the RNC have
said that they want to compromise are
you willing to meet them in the middle
here of course we will always in engage
we will continue to
engage uh with the RCN and uh with
others what I have sought to explain to
you and indeed to your viewers is to
understand why the government is taking
this approach we're trying to be
reasonable in relation to this however
we do have to balance off The Wider
public considerations in the in relation
to this this is what you would expect
ministers to do in this kind of scenario
and I have to say to to to the the union
leaders we will continue to be
reasonable but we also must be Resolute
in terms of protecting The Wider public
finances and that's a difficult argument
to make I accept it's a difficult
argument to make and I would dearly love
just to to for the government to be able
to write the check for a massive uh for
an increase in in public sector pay but
we've we've put it through this public
sector pay review bodies and we're
taking a reasonable and balanced
approach and I would urge the unions to
take a similarly reasonable approach
Oliver Dalton the chancellor of the
justee of Lancaster thank you very much
for joining us on Sky News today